as a native new yorker
i'd be new york to vote in new york
tell you a citizen
i guess the bottom line is i have a
little bit of a problem with that
i feel as long as they're educated about
politics and politicians and i think
that's great
oh i support that
yeah i have to say i i don't agree with
it i do not agree with it
why should that
they're not
they're not familiar
an american citizen has the right to
vote and i believe that that is
important that we you know maintain that
that level of integrity that's
awesome
well because be very straightforward the
people the 800 000 that get to vote are
the people who also live here so it's
going to affect their community they
should also have their own voice they
should also be able to vote so i
absolutely love that and my parents are
also immigrants so this is like
beautiful to hear i had no idea this was
happening
[Music]
i personally like the freedom that
people should have but i feel they
should be citizens before they're
allowed to vote in any election i think
that if these elections affect their
lives and livelihoods
they should possibly have an opportunity
to
[Music]
express that
in a voting manner
if they live here and they work here and
they pay taxes so
they should have the right to
vote
and yeah i think it's a good idea
well if they're living here but they're
on a working visa i mean i guess they
should have say as to what's going on in
the city right
it's a great country people do want to
come here and better their lives and
better their families lives and one of
the things i think we can do better is
make it easier for people to come here
make it easier for people to get
citizenship and help them but i do think
we should keep the standard as
citizenship is what gives you your right
to vote and then that keeps that that
pride and honor in place for for the
people who have done it